Mike Bocchetti sitting in and look who's
just joined us Robert Patrick hey guys
welcome man how are you fantastic it's
good to be here what's good guys it's
good to have you here it's good to be
anywhere does that do you practice that
voice or is that just
oh I don't know I mean all over I guess
yeah it says voice I've used before I
don't know just to be able to walk into
a studio and say good to be here like I
I probably notice it more because I have
for somebody that works in this medium
have a traditionally what's known as a
shitty radio voice you have a good boy
you think so yeah absolutely you already
pick up on that yeah I like it yeah see
here my voice is going way up here now
see so you were just doing an exercise
fine Johnny Cash voice that's amazing
training no believe it or not would you
consider it of course yeah I think it's
good what kind of vocal training have
you had I've singing singing training
vocal coaches do that I also people that
teach you how to get down in your your
diaphragm down here and find your voice
down here and now you learning to sing
just to learn how to better use your
voice or you actually want to sing in
some of these films or whatever uh well
I started just to enhance my my acting
just learned my voice a little more and
learn how to to use it in different ways
and I just produced a film and star in a
film that is out right now you can
stream right now it's it's I'm very very
proud of it it's called last rampage
true story true crime story is reading
about last night escape of Gary Tison
yes a very very bad man
and my brother who is a multi-platinum
recording artist Richard Patrick you
know he's got a band filter and he was
the former guitarist Lawrence nails he
did the score for the movie and wrote
two original songs and came to me after
the movie was over and said you know I
know you sang with Alejandro Escovedo in
Austin Texas how do you like singing and
I
I I dig it I enjoy it you know he said I
want you to sing a song from the movie
and let's record it so I went in with
his band and recorded my first song and
have a song that's that's out on a
soundtrack right do you like it
I love it you like the song I like the
song yeah I I hate to be that guy but I
don't mind it it refreshing
most people come in yeah most people
come in they're like I can't watch my
own stuff I can't listen to my own stuff
and you're like yeah and and you know
they do the movie and I can't see I want
to see the movie once
uh-huh twice maybe you know three times
maybe you're getting into it a little
bit too much but you've got it I think
personally the way I look at it you want
to see if you're doing what you think
you're doing right right and you also
want to see where you can improve so
like my TV show scorpion I'll watch it
once every episode though yeah just yeah
one time and and I'm okay why I just
want to make sure I'm on track you have
to be disciplined to do that though I
think you can't have that that sort of
insecurity in you where you're like
watching yourself it's got to be an
exercise in like you said in improvement
like it's got to be like I know why I'm
doing this and I'm really worried about
whether or not I have the ability to act
at this point you're confident yeah yeah
no I'm confident I know what I'm doing
yeah and and you know in the old days
the old days yeah back when they film
things and they used to screen dailies
at lunch you know you as an actor you
had an opportunity to you want to sit in
on the dailies and and see what's going
on and I think it was useful to a lot of
actors I know there's there's actors
that didn't do that but but you always
did I if I had the opportunity to go to
daily yeah I wanted to see if I was on
track with what I what I thought I was
trying to do although you see something
you're doing that you don't like and
it's bad but if it's dramatic what are
you gonna change it up and then like one
scene in the movie you're like this love
and the rest of it you're great well
that's where you kind of go like you
know what geez if you want to reshoot
that scene maybe we should try it you
know yes those things kind of come off
what about when you're in like a like a
like a movie that is one of those movies
that people do watch over and over again
t-too obviously is one that people talk
about but there have been a bunch of
things that you've done that people
watch over and over again can you
take yourself out of it to the point
where you're like no it's just one of my
favorite movies or because you're so
close to it that doesn't happen yeah
well I think Terminator 2 is one of the
greatest films ever made
yeah in any genre I think it's a pretty
damn perfect film and I realized that
I'm commenting on myself being in that
but I mean a big part of a play but they
could have had somebody else come in and
do it maybe they've done an even better
job but I I'm comfortable enough and I
don't think I'm being too much of an
egomaniac to say that I'm happy with the
way it turned out
if you say something like that you
better be sure that people agree with
you like you come off like an egomaniac
if you say it about a movie that's not
Terminator 2 right right I gotta be
pretty sure it's taken me 27 years to
kind of work up to that but we recently
re-released the film in 3d and having
seen it again and not having looked at
it in a long time you know I feel pretty
comfortable saying that I think the
story is there I think that none of the
elements in that movie are there for the
sake of being you know effects yeah
they're there to help tell the story and
I think it's a timely thing I'll give
you a for instance how timely it is Elon
Musk has said that artificial
intelligence is probably the biggest
threat we have as a nation
dude I talk about it all the time when I
see these like even even when I see like
a good news New York State has gone
cashless tolls I go if that's how it's
started they start replacing jobs you're
you're you're dependent on your phone
and then all of a sudden see that's what
I say like people are like well what do
you mean like how could a machine become
smarter than you and I go because what
if Siri wasn't just learning from you
what if Siri was one thing that was
learning from everybody
yeah and now this thing has learned not
from one person but from everybody the
minute you've got a machine that figures
out how to make machines
yeah and it's smarter than you yeah
humans are done Hey what what did he
just say about they were shutting down
somebody shut down their AI part of
their business who was it was a Google I
didn't they shut it down because they
said wait a minute they're communicating
with themselves it's for real
right I'd read that I read that story oh
yeah okay so in a language that we
couldn't understand yeah so we don't
even know what the hell they're doing
that's right that's freaking that's the
movie so alright ai-ai-ai-aight met a
gal who's an engineer for us at SpaceX
hmm she invited me to come see the
rocket builds so I go to SpaceX to see
the rocket builds alright yeah so I'm
walking in there now there's a server
room and the server room is this blue
hue kind of like the color of your walls
so and it goes deep right yes and you're
walking in and I look and there's a row
after row after row after row of servers
always just goes on and on and on this
is blue hue but right in front on the
inside I see something that looks
vaguely familiar to me and I'm looking
at it and I read it it says Cyberdyne
systems right right that's from my move
of course it is it was the prop from the
movie that was the marker that was
filmed out in front of the building that
said Cyberdyne really his you know
Cyberdyne systems when they do the
establishing shot cut - and I say to her
and she looks at me and she goes oh yeah
he's a fan Wow
it's happening dude it's happening it's
just that it's happening but you see so
ok with it no I'm not ok with it I'm
furious that crapless room because so I
went over to Sara Sidle bridge for the
first time yeah and I was actually as
literally I was thinking about it this
morning because it go past one of these
bridges right and the sign says all
everything in New York stays cashless
tolls right I know I'm going back to the
cashless tolls yeah but the sign says if
you have an EZ Pass it's like two
dollars and 34 cents if you don't have
an EZ Pass we'll send you a bill for six
dollars and I go thing are that invested
in making sure that every vehicle has an
EZ Pass yeah they want you on that
program yes they want you on that
program well that's what's kind of going
on in California they want us out of our
cars right they want us now to continue
building the metro and developing a
public transportation system ie what you
guys have here right they want us
they want to get us out of their cars
why what they would say to diminish
traffic right I don't I don't know where
I'm going with this but I'll tell you
what it's kind of like well what is your
car your car is personal freedom yes not
of course I love so are they trying to
take my personal freedom no no no they
are in the way I see that's why I don't
like those self-driving cars they drive
me crazy who in their right mind is
gonna give up the fun of driving your
own car and then to be like to the
machine
you got this night market you got it no
problem I'm gonna relax on this one you
take or now I know I know you do I test
drove one of those cars that self
parallel parks it is the creepiest
oddest thing and it just feels like
submitting I know it's these little
steps but that's how it starts the
little steps you're right and you're
just submitting because they're like no
don't worry your phones can make
everything easier don't worry you don't
have to worry about parallel parking
anymore like this is just easy stuff and
then it's like also they're gonna cook
your food for you
let us do that for you now come lie in
this chamber and sleep we'll put you to
sleep forever exactly how about this one
now the new the new the new gimmick all
the stuff you're talking about a
soldier's life I mean like right in
Skype yeah I might go to my Judy Jetson
it might be might be I'm afraid of that
you know how about this game it's really
watching me wait till you hear this one
because I figured this whole thing is
good so in New York they're all about
protesting for minimum wage right
everybody's protesting to get the
minimum wage increase and I'm trying to
tell these people what are you guys
thinking with these protests because I'm
watching it happen they protest the
fast-food restaurants to increase
minimum wage as if like you know we're
supposed to be making a live
and they're appealing to the
humanitarian and everyone that's like
well they should of course they should
make a livable ways so you know what
McDonald's does they go okay no problem
we'll increase them the minimum wage two
months later they start testing out the
new iPad ordering systems where there's
no servers whoa
that's what they do you all right no
problem you know what I did not know
about that but that is interesting yes
because if we do start demanding certain
things I mean the cut I don't know you
know what it costs to run a McDonald's I
don't know how it is but I'm sure that
you know the equation that works out the
people you're paying have to make X
amount of money right or the business
model doesn't work right and if you come
in there and say you know what we demand
more money and it's the cost of doing
business goes up well you know then
there had a choice of what are we gonna
do we got to save money somewhere we're
literally at the point where we have to
calculate what is our value as a human
being right what is the economic value
to a company to hire human as opposed to
a machine and if I ask for higher than
that value then they're gonna go for a
machine they're gonna go for a machine
and I become obsolete then what am I
gonna do right exactly
what what do I do now what's my new
special you know what do I specialize in
what what what do I have what's my
talent what makes me unique Mike what do
we do that's scary what do we do my just
try to gain control back again I mean
it's like double you know like the
McDonald's thing yeah because we throw
an iPad in the dumpster up to this you
know I mean they don't care about
anything
throw the iPad people so they're even
gonna be mean to the Machine of course
we're not gonna recharge you hey that
iPad has a family when your battery
fails you fail oh my god you know you
know what I like I was talking about you
that you never I feel like you're not
you're not as precious as a lot of
actors are and I get that from you when
we talk about like watching your stuff
and like that you can watch it back and
do it as a craft I also like in
hindsight people when they get a role
like you got in Terminator they'll
sometimes start to try to get away from
it and try to not acknowledge it be like
why
want to be this guy don't want to be
typecast but you realize like this is
only a good thing yeah like like not
that you overdid it and said hey I'm the
Terminator because you've done Wayne's
World but you did the way you were a
thing and a lot of people wouldn't have
done that and I thought it was a
brilliant thing and I ended up doing it
again for for Arnold in Last Action Hero
yeah and and yeah and the weird thing is
and I've had this discussion with my
wife and friends you know I was an
unknown when I got that role which
benefited the role because you didn't
have a preconceived notion of who I was
so you accept me as that character the
character itself is much more famous
than I ever was I did find myself in a
position where once it was over I didn't
work for a year and a half I couldn't
get a job and how and the reason was I
think is is every time I walked in a
room I still look like that thing sure
so it dawned on me I'm but perhaps I
should change the way I look so I gained
some weight I grew my hair long I grew a
beard and lo and behold I did get cast
and fire in the sky yeah which is an
alien movie it is a little bit of that
Terminator world in a weird way but it
was a very real guy the true story and a
true story and you don't play an alien
you're it's a dramatic I be it's a
dramatic role and that sort of changed
things for me it got the director didn't
even realize it was the same actor so he
was casting me on my on my abilities and
and so you know in a weird way it was
like I'm totally comfortable making fun
of that character but in the same
respect I had to be leery of I don't
want to be typecast that way and a lot
of some of the things that were being
offered to me at the time were a robot
or something similarly and I'm like you
got to be kidding me I'm even having
people offering me commercials to do
then it gets to the point where you yeah
they're not having fun with it you're
just trying to yeah that role I don't
want to that's not me I'm I'm a serious
actor mm-hm and I want to I want to do
different things so really that's what
I've been doing for the last 27 28 29
years is trying to do as many different
very roles as I can
to get to create the body of work that I
have right now and and it's it's it's
been great and it seemed I feel like you
never know exactly what's gonna hit like
for me every time I think about you I
think of that I think it was like a
three-episode arc on The Sopranos paper
point my career I mean it way and it was
such a strong thing cuz I brought that
up probably a month ago when we were
talking about gambling on the show which
is because like you just watch this guy
who was like just this absolutely
relatable dad who owned a store who was
just America Sporting Goods guy yeah
yeah I was but then to watch every she
was such a maniac I'm like and he was
but you're even had sympathy for me on
some level he didn't want me to do it I
mean we're all high school buddies but
it's interesting what you were saying
was you know there was a pivotal point
in my career where I was still trying to
prove to people like again you it's like
if you heard the nillas that guy from
the I I don't know if he'd be right for
this role because they they they they
now have a conception a concept of what
they think I am as an actor without you
know seeing me doing something else
right it's such a strong the iconic kind
of a character that I played so when
that was offered to me I had another
movie on the line that somebody was
offering me to do and for a great sum of
money or go do this movie for HBO for
pretty much scale yeah and and my acting
coach and I agreed that it would be the
best thing for me to do would be this
the david scatino on The Sopranos
because everybody in Hollywood watched
it and I will knock it out of the
ballpark and David Chase had given me a
great gift he said you know Robert no
one would cast you this way you are a
pathetic gambler you're gonna get [ __ ]
slapped around by Tony Soprano you cry
like a baby it's no one's gonna catch
you this way yeah and he was right but
it was great I mean it's right and you
and you related to it as because those
are things that like because you relate
to The Sopranos characters in a way like
when they start getting into their
families and stuff but the whole Mafia
element is
oh yeah outside the realm of what could
possibly happen to me is the average
dude right but you and it doesn't that's
is how an average dude stumbles in that
world and yeah sucked up into vol all
that bravado from that yeah machismo
that goes on with that and if you get in
debt to me all of a sudden things get
real right maybe my friend no and he's
like yeah hey let's go get my favors
when in the episode two right this is
what I love about this character and
I've only watched this once but I
remember when they got me up on the the
pool table do you remember this and then
my wife comes down and she's you know
I'm trying to kill myself up there
forgot where I was for second I'm trying
to you know whatever I'm trying to break
it you know just failing it back to [ __ ]
I mean to me the moment the scumbag move
of just pretending that you're mad at
your son's that you can give your car no
time what a [ __ ] piece of garbage got
his car now yeah well that kid went on
to that kid that the young man had
played my son was one of the one of my
characters my side characters when I was
in Sons of Anarchy yeah I should show
they're doing the pilot right now for
Mayans right which is the spin-off of
Sons of Anarchy involved in Mayans I
love that I hope so
CBS Monday nights yes Monday nights of
corene o'clock lore comes out Friday the
13th Flo last rampage is available video
on demand right now me
I produced it it's the darkest it I
really want to say something about last
rampage if you don't mind we're about a
minute left in the show it's a great
movie it's one of the my eye I really
want people to see this and I'd my
brother did do the score and there is a
song from from me to you to all of you